explosive intensification these are the
words to State whether Bureau in the
Philippines used to describe a
strengthening typhoon noru as it
approached the island nation on Sunday
it was a category 5 when it hit land
sending waves crashing onto Shores and
bringing with it powerful winds and
torrential rains
in a matter of 24 hours the fiercest
winds increased by nearly 100 kilometers
an hour one of the fastest acceleration
on record
the most vulnerable people those along
the coast in low-lying communities and
in areas prone to landslides had only
hours to scramble to safety
thirteen years ago scores of people died
in a village where this school is
located after typhoon kitsana created
flash floods so now many don't need to
be told they've already evacuated their
homes
the memory is fresh on their minds many
of their neighbors drowned and their
bodies were never found
our house went underwater we weren't
able to salvage any of our belongings
we've been afraid of typhoon since
katsana and especially now that I've had
a baby loru is the most powerful storm
to batter the Philippines this year
comparisons were quickly drawn to
katsana in several Cyclones that
followed government officials pledged to
save as many lives as possible
and Equipment ahead of time we've got
rescue swimmers inflatable boats divers
and medical units
air and sea travel as well as Government
work in school classes have been
suspended until Monday at least
when noro is expected to leave the
country
partner below Al Jazeera Manila